yes today I want to talk about the
something that does fun for me and I
think some of you might also enjoy it
too it's the idea of quotations at the
beginning or end or middle of play book
chapter or sometimes even a technical
paper and for this I I guess the first
thing to say is a lot of people have
written a lot of neat things and and not
all of us have seen them all and so when
when we see something that we
particularly like it's nice to be able
to pass that around to a greater
authorship by highlighting it somewhere
other letting other people know that it
exists and so that's one of the one of
the fun's about having of having
quotations now the last few years I I
was working on the tech and meta phone
systems and i'm going to use most of my
examples coming from coming from that
also interact with writing in some ways
that's why it's not so inappropriate to
this course and all of this there's a a
journal has been published it's in vol 8
now this year called the tugboat the
tech user group newsletter and one of
the things in their in their format is
that they have a quotation at the
beginning of every of every issue and
here's one for example about writing
Sinclair Lewis felt his writing and
suffered in the 30s because during his
marriage he had let her talking with
using professional typist to make the
final drafts of his scripts he now
regretted following her advice was
convinced that if an author didn't do
his own retyping revising and proving as
he went he lost some control over his
work and Faulkner on O'Hara also did
this too it is this is a quotation that
was used benim in tugboat and here's a
quotation from fowler no attempt will be
made here to describe modern english
usage in the matter of hyphens it's
infinite variety defies description
there is one principle our that seems to
come in at least lip service and that is
the hyphen is not an ornament but
aid to being understood and should be
employed sort of when it helps helps the
understanding okay so this is some
fowler another quote here is saying that
we need artists to be programmers and
here was one that that was for the
recent issue here we appreciate all you
would point out our errors here's how to
keep scarf and find six errors or more
your professional 325 makes you a
trainee less than three makes your
desktop publisher this is the trend of
things nothing's okay now so they begin
with with quotations and one question is
how do you how do you find these
quotations well one thing is you just if
you if you live a reasonably varied life
words are around you all the time and
every once in a while you happen to
stumble into something that's
particularly a patrol in fact you
stumble into something that's that's
particularly apropos out of context too
often now wait were you where you can
see something in a different way on one
of my favorites is that I was some it
actually in volume for I have a lot of
things coming up that I planning to use
as quotations in vying for of the art of
computer programming and this is one of
the read the things that keeps me going
and saying I do want to write that
volume because I have such nice
quotations that I can't you know I the
texans going to have to be written to
but I but I'm really going to be glad
when I talk about backtracking and I can
refer to the beatles on it there's
nobody in my tree and and and and
there's and the one that one of the
things at the beginning is is about
techniques of a bit fiddling and I
noticed that in Webster's dictionary the
definition of a bit is that it's a
boring tool and are boring tool and
and I thought that would that would work
rather well for computer scientist so I
was going to use this as a as a joke in
him as an introduction to a lecture I
gave about bit fiddling in Germany but
as I as I was driving to the University
to give this lecture I noticed there was
a bumper sticker on the on the car in
front of me or was it on a sign on the
truck in front of me said bitte ein bit
and it turns out that there's a that
there's beer brewed in Bitburg bit
burgers replace that one of those places
Ronald Reagan would like to forget about
it and and they also have Bitburg there
and there and so there their slogan is
behind it so I could use you know that
kind of quotation and now well you so if
you just keep your eyes open you'll see
things that are worth them that are
worth worth repeating another thing is
though suppose that you you want to
actually find the court eight you know
you've got a format and and their format
calls for having a quotation at the
beginning of every chat hello nope no
commercials on television is this right
I'm sorry I didn't know they think you
can't buy that beer here no ok um ok I'm
sorry I didn't hear anything now so but
then there's then you have the other
question that is if you you have a
format that sort of requires you to have
these these visas and so you'd like to
you'd like to do sort of the best job
and say what's the best possible
quotation I could use on topic x and
solve for x and that's what that's the
thing i want to address the rest of this
the rest of this hour the various
techniques that that i have used in
order to in order to do
that is in other words uh in in the tech
book for example the let's see where's
the table of contents it has 27 chapters
and and 10 appendices 37 places where
where I need quotations and the format
called for two quotations at the end of
each and so that was 37 times 274 so
fine 70 for quotation then it then came
the marathon book which was the same
format so I need n and it turned out
that by great coincidence it also oh
there's a preface as well I'm sorry
there's so that's 76 quotations so they
were again 27 chapters and 10 appendices
and and and and and a preface of so
anyway the the idea is to try to find
quotations that that reefer that reflect
ok now that chapter one is the name of
the game ok and here's the quotation and
so I was trying to figure out something
about names and this chapters about the
name tech itself and since it's about
the name tech itself I I actually was
able to get up a quotation about
technique which is has to also connects
it somehow with art and the point of the
of the chapter is that the word tech
comes from Greek root that means art and
as well as technique the same the same
Greek word technique it comes has led to
both has led to both things this turned
out to be a Stanford author by the way
who who is a poet about you know it's
about this time in a minute and appeared
in some it was some Stanford guide that
i never had heard of before how did I
how did I find this into this particular
code well I don't know I might have
looked up technique in Bartlett's
familiar quotations
and so let's take a look is there now
there's there are many books like this
but Bartlett's is probably the one
that's best known and so in this book it
has lots and lots of things that are
worth that are sort of the most
according to Bartletts idea was the most
memorable things that these people wrote
and goes on and on by Byron Keats
McCauley browning Fitzgerald tennis and
Melville dickinson Twain Miller Hopkins
field so on and so on and then at the
end you can look up the even look up
individual words and so if I so if I
look up technique I might find well
let's see where is it technique okay
well there was only one reference to
technique it says technique the very
word 937 and so I probably looked it up
and said it wasn't you know didn't
didn't connect it to art or anything
like that I wanted to know well here it
is yes this is it Leonard bacon this is
where I got it what do you know
technique the very word is like ash
recover okay so that's where I got that
one and it was a it's a something called
PhDs and so it's at 1920 at Stanford I
wrote it in here this is where I found
at the library at 11.4 and then I ok and
so I I give away that first secret
namely no Bartlett's quotations now
that's a that's an easy well there's
there's many other books of quotations
in the reference room and and there are
books of quotations that are translated
from other languages there are ten quote
there are things called the quotable
woman there are quotations from black
literature there are quotations from
folk sayings and different cultures and
there are
there are quotations from different
kinds of groups and there's complete
concordances to Shakespeare and Chaucer
so every word that those people ever
wrote you could find somewhere in it
nice in these in these books i guess i
have to say that one of the things that
for me is the most fun to do if i have
if i have to say what what do I enjoy
most in life I mean I enjoy various
things like playing music and things but
one of the hot one of the highest for me
is to go into a library and have some
problem to solve any any any problem
whatsoever but to try to sort of play
the library as if it was an ordinary
other as an instrument to to to you too
to use the resources of a great library
to solve some problem or other and one
of the neat problems is to take is to is
to take a particular theme and see if I
can find a good quotation somewhere in
the library and how to do that no if
this might not turn up turn you all on
but for me this is this is the this is
really living and and in a reference and
and so it came like I had you know so I
love to go to Stanford library for an
afternoon and with an idea of here I'm
supposed to find 76 quotations how many
can I find today and i'll be happy if i
can find 20 good one by dennis in the
British Museum Library and I Harvard a
little when I was doing a marathon book
I had the Widener Library of Harvard and
boston public librarian and there's you
know many other great libraries and you
know do things at Berkeley and and New
York and Philadelphia and so on now the
Princeton yeah so now each of these
reference rooms has a different
collection of these are these books of
quotations and selves and so you can and
they're usually reasonably well indexed
so you can look in the back and
you can you can get some idea and so
that's a that's a beginning of a big
inning of how how how to do it and and
some of the things are very easy to find
quotations so then you've got it but
then you've got to do the next the next
level and and get a really good
quotation now here's for example is a
chapter called fine points of
mathematics typing and I needed I had
four chapters in a robot mathematics and
so I needed some something interesting
to say about about about about
mathematics and so I like this one which
I had I just heard about it somewhere
mathematicians are like Frenchman
whatever you say to them they translated
into their own language and once it is
something entirely different and now
here's an is a very good one apropos to
our course it says the best notation is
no notation this is remember your
homework assignments whenever it is
possible to avoid the use of a
complicated alphabetic apparatus avoided
good attitude to the preparation of
written mathematical exposition is
pretend it is spoken pretend that you
are explaining to a friend in a long
work on a long walk in the woods with no
paper available fall back on symbolism
only one it's really necessary this is
from that how much as I mentioned him
before all right how did he does Lauren
breaks now the line breaks on the gun by
myself by hand on this right when when
something is flush right the only way to
if any kind of automatic braking looks
bad if it's flush right bracket left
like this and and so I I would play with
these until I got up to the point where
I liked them and each one each one was
individually played with but speaking of
line breaks there's uh there's his
here's a chapter on line breaks
this is health tech breaks paragraphs in
two lines okay so when the author
objects to a hyphenation you should be
asked to add or cancel or substitute a
word or words that will prevent it or
authors who insist on even spacing
always slightly divisions always do not
clearly understand the rigidity of types
in this acceptable I had come across
this when I was reading the history of
the of what printers do when they when
they do line breaking here was the one
by Shaw said that whenever William
Morris found a line at justified awkward
eip altered the wording to make it
solely for the sake of making it look
well in print and i must say i do that
when a proof has been sent me with two
or three lines so widely spaced make a
grave and i've often rewritten it so
it's phillip the lines better i'm sorry
to say that my objects which have been
so little understood the compiler has
fault all the rest of the paragraph
instead of mending the former bad word
so so that's you also have to have
control over the type over the over the
spacing yourself if you hear the author
and you rewrite it so that it's going to
look better but then somebody else
doesn't understand your intention that
screws up the other way but speaking of
that though the format of this book the
book designer designed it with a very
long paragraph indentation of normally
large indentation here and this this saw
is also seems to be a style of the 80s i
think the Harvard Business Review I
noticed a magazine has this I ran across
this once a year or two ago and and
something that you noticed immediately
when you start using that format is that
it's not that unusual for a paragraph to
end with just one word or two words
which is less than the length of the
indentation of the pair craft indent and
so I had to rewrite a lot of paragraphs
to add a couple of words at the end in
order to make it in order to make it
look not look that the book designer you
know who makes it make a nice-looking
book because it was a theme that was
carried carried through in all the other
problems of the format that this end
indentation helped to unify the book
design but it was it was difficult for
the you know for rewriting to make it
look good because there are a lot of
cases whoa I mean you can imagine on a
hundred pages of 400 paragraphs what are
the chances that you'll get all possible
distributions and and you have to have
to rewrite for that mm-hmm okay now and
these are things that I just ran across
while I was studying the while I was
looking up what people had to say about
about printing so there was so that was
not South in a particular way now what's
this one displayed equation so here is
talking about printing of mathematics
with an how and just some comments that
people had made about about the straight
equations nothing funny there is i won't
i won't go on what about macros now here
was the one I had a chapter called
definitions also known macros know how
would I find a suitable quote for for
that well I this one was this one had me
working for a while I went up to I found
a first of all I found Israelis court i
hate definitions was fairly was fairly
good but but then i turned out that that
i found that macro was the the name of a
corrupt Roman politician and and so in
all history books it was possible to try
to get a quote about about this macro
nerd who
who didn't last very long but he got
into he got into a few places there okay
now let me see how did I stumble across
his name I i believe i was looking into
all the oxford english dictionary
wouldn't have helped me here but oxford
english dictionary is a good source for
the hard ones because they have
quotations of they cite the word in its
historical context and and often they
should they choose interesting
interesting things to side but but this
particular one I must have gotten gotten
it through some index or other that it
just happened to notice anything else
we've got your alignment okay this is
talking about making tables lining
things into columns and and so I and so
here I thought okay I'll do it to
something a little different I'll quote
want to do DNI's puzzles which was about
about putting things into rows and
columns and then the end then the answer
pages actually has a solution to this
puzzle so in the quotation and then
hearing and I like I get to Christy so I
was reading a one of her novels and I
noticed that they talked about fifth
columnist and so honest I seem to be
something I could I could appreciate I
could appropriate here now the title of
her book of her book nrm reminds me that
i have another book here which came up
in this series of computer and
typesetting which is all about about
letter forms can you back off of this to
get the page spread and all the symbols
each in this book every letter it is
given with an you know with a computer
program on there i 10 pages that during
the probe the letters on me on the left
hand pages and in order to lighten this
up I I put quotations on the bottom
every once in a while of
where it would refer to things I didn't
have too many quotations in this
particular section obviously but I know
I do have some coming in here before a
long okay well mostly when I get into
the letters I had some things to say
here's the page with a semicolon in it
and and there was a and my wife had
remembered that she that she had read
something that she memorable about
semicolons where there's a Somerset
Maugham story about a an author who had
had discovered the comic possibilities
of the semicolon and she and she was she
had a humor of punctuation in her
writing and I wanted to show you this
this quote because Mary Claire I
understand who's going to be our you
know our lecturer in a couple of weeks
is sometimes called Miss cama like
there's Miss Manners you know and so on
and so she's supposed to know I don't
know about if she's thority on
semicolons but she's supposed to be
especially good about commas and and and
so try to I so there are too many
quotations about particular letters but
here was one that I well let me go back
to this one first I got one from church
James Thurber has a story called the
wonderful oh and and this is a
children's story that where he's trying
to teach them the alphabet and but he
about the abolish is all the O's in in
his story and then in the page on E I
had room for a quote here which is a
from a very interesting bell labs report
by by Gilbert called a capacity former
formula for a binary communication link
in which rung output digits occur in
bursts our work also has cryptographic
and linguistic application now if you
look very closely he gives the clue here
to his whole quote here it says in
particular writing contains only 25
symbols abcdefg and cozy that's a symbol
of maximum probability and ordinary
writing is missing from ours he wrote
this entire report without using the
letter e except in his own name
which is which he couldn't help and so
that and and read through the report and
it's actually actually proves it a
reasonable mathematical theorem but he
could see such as an extra constraint
that he just wouldn't use anymore any
words that had had the letter e in them
here's Bierce now beer Souza wrote the
you know he was a famous San Franciscan
who wrote the the devil's dictionary and
many other he was a pink had regular
columns in that was at The Chronicle or
the examiner I don't know anyway he and
so I read through the devil's dictionary
because it was likely to have something
quotable besides a lot of fun and here
he's talking about about the letter M he
said two schools of em stirs whether the
letter his henceforth has two sides of a
triangle or three sides of a square and
and he's talking about you know style of
shaping of the letter M and so this was
appropriate for the page in which we
have letter M in there here's a here's
something that I I snow hi Benjamin
Franklin was was interested in in
typography and so he he writes a letter
to bodoni the inventor of this of the
type style very similar to the one that
I'm that I'm mom showing in this book
here and and he but he doesn't like the
letter team in bedok nice title page and
and so he writes him a letter saying
this now I
how did I find that particular reference
believe I was invited to give a talk in
the Franklin Institute and I was and I
was started to read read about Benjamin
Franklin's interest in in printing
because of that okay one of the courts
at the beginning of this book is is
about the whole style of type and that I
followed in the book and that is and
adds a sock so this is a kind of letter
is capable of greater vulgarity and
degradation it was ever the case with
older fonts so in other words a lot of
people don't care for this style of
letters that I that I've got in these
books throughout history now see the
most fun I think comes when you can when
you can take things a bit out of context
and let's see this one is called output
routines and I and I didn't know how to
get what to say about about outputs but
I got leontief had published a lot about
he was a famous economist who had who
had things about about input-output his
input output system and so I thought if
I read enough of his stuff i could find
that he used the word out put in some
way that would be that would be also
interpret interpret of oil with respect
to to type to typography and an
algorithm so on and so here are
technical has something to do with text
i guess and things like this and there's
there's a there's something about
changes in output so i don't know now
summary was hard one i had three
chapters called summary summary of
vertical mode then summary of horizontal
mode a summary of math
and how was I going to get six different
quotations about summary and then 6 mar
for the marathon book so so but I didn't
realize I had the marathon book to do
when I started with this one so first of
all this is summary of vertical mode and
and i was and i found one reasonably
relevant thing probably in the oxford
english dictionary but then this one was
was amazing to me that i was able to
find something with was was talking
about verticality of composition and
modes because you know had Vertical in
mode in the same in the same sentence
now you could do that if you had all
these texts online in a computer you
could say you know which sentences have
vertical and mode in it but but this was
a it was talking about architecture and
but that was I believe it I found it
under mode probably in in the indecision
air technology summary of horizontal
mode there's a there was a quote that
said you may reduce all verticals into
horizontals and and incidentally I in
this chapter I had referred back to the
vertical mode chapter 2 I mean
everything a lot of the things in
vertical also applied to horizontal and
Moxon happened to be also a book who a
man who wrote a famous book on printing
so this would this turned out to be a
amazing amazing fine between when I must
have found that just by looking up for
for quotes are in Oxford English
Dictionary about vertical horizontal but
then I was running short and so I I need
something about horizontal mode so i got
the quote tech itself and in a pinch you
can always write you can always quote
yourself
and and professor spits in history
department said that chi-lites young man
had come to him who is writing a book
and wanted some you know and ask s spits
person for some ideas and spits then
came had three or four but he couldn't
think of the other one he said so God I
said you know you just said okay then
you say something just give me anything
and I can quote you if this was
different this was a reasonable quote
for also for the meaning of the of the
of the chapter and in summary of math MO
and what today could I do there oh here
i was able to to take one from the style
manual chicago press to saying that
Mathis is tough and expensive but here
was here was afoot here was one that
turned out that i had discovered by
being interested in wales that there was
a there was a folk tale about someone
named math in in the matlab in olean the
the list goes on now little before time
of King Arthur I think and and it and
the translator he's a professor at UCLA
who who has some neat correspondence
with trying to learn more about math and
so on he he's the one who told me how to
hyphenate some Welsh words that I used
in in example but he but so anyway this
has both math and summary in in in the
sentence and so I could get could I
could confine the tool here and series
huh now let's just but talking about
summary I should go to the next one this
is for errors as another that last
chapter is about recovery from errors
and and there's there's a lot of neat
things to say about error but now let's
go to the meta funk book I had the same
three
had to do summary chapters they're not
not not quite as many summary of
expressions was was there and I'm
running out of things to say about
summaries and so I i got i had to use
expressions here so i got to talk about
Expressionists i guess like by looking
into him into one of the novels that was
God's where the his novels were
serialized on public television what's
the name of the series I can't think of
it anyway but then Thomas More had
written about about things that were
well remembered and something summarily
rehearsed and so it's used that one and
and then there is a things about the
language as a whole in Creek fruit and
detail and so I I try I I tried to get
some quotations about details in fact I
worked very hard about that about
Trenton because a lot of the of a user
manuals is inevitably filled with
details and and there's and and so I had
heard I had heard that see the architect
of our house told told us that Mies van
der Rohe had always said talk to
students that God is in the details and
that this is for him I mean he was one
like me who like minutiae and focusing
on getting details straight you see what
God was yes and also means yes and and
so I wanted to find where this where
means had said this so like a quote me
knees is the same God is in the details
in fact I I had said I had used it in a
lecture once and somebody came up to me
and afterwards said that was a wonderful
quotation from me as you know almost so
then I so I started looking through all
of meeses publications and I couldn't
find a single a single
thing and and then I finally uh but so I
i wrote to two of the people who who had
recently written biographies of me's and
I and I and I also met an architect in
boston and he said yes he had heard this
he wanted he was interested in helping
me find this code code also so I got
back finally a reference to a man who
who said this was this is something that
means like to say and he had published
this in architectural form I couldn't
get a direct reference I read a lot of
meeza speeches where he would had a
chance to say it and never said it and
and then I then there was this other
biography oh yeah and one of the bog
refers wrote back to me said yet this
was a thought this was you know a lot of
people have said the Mesa that this was
one of me as his favorite favorite
Maxim's but they didn't know he could
assure me that means had said it but he
didn't know aware and then and then I
got another reference to somebody who
says no these never did say this but but
people have have but but actually it
comes from French French essayist who
wrote millions of things saying lay bone
do a Sulha did town or something i can't
i have a terrible French accent or
something like this but giving no
reference whatsoever so I started
looking through French books of
quotations and under this and I can icon
for if I really neat things about
details and but not but never yet have I
have I discovered the source of this of
this phrase God is in the details I am
still hoping for it well here was the
opposite approach with with 40 saying
your life is frittered away by detail
you should forget about details recovery
from errors this is one of my favorite
oh this is one of my favorite poems here
perhaps my favorite of all oh you can
read it for yourself by piet hein I'm
having this this carved in I'm having
this carved in stone and may I buy some
calligraphy by some stone cutters in
England to the gods to keep in my garden
I just like this I think it's a fairly
fairly good summary of one of my models
in life is to not be afraid to make
mistakes but try to learn from them is
on now the other quote here is is by
father font and since I this is a book
about fonts I I knew that if the end I
know then I learned that there was a
friendship Spanish explorer who was one
of the first people to come to
California in the in the portola
expedition and his and he was the one
who kept the diary of the trip and and
so his name was font and I and so great
he must say something in there that I
can quote just because his name is font
that would that would be the relevant
and now in fact the directions of the
route is also something kind of thing
that you do when you're drawing letters
and so so this turnout but I had to read
his whole diary in order to find that
one it was fascinating though yeah it
was i didn't i didn't mind a minute of
it i mean he he recalls about the
politics of the situation and any put
his whole he did I'm thinking oh he knew
this tire was going to be for
publication particularly and but he was
writing it for his other the other
fellows in his jesuit colleagues in in
Mexico and so I talked to the man who
who took father fonts role in the
Bicentennial reenactment of the portola
expedition they they went but from
Mexico and came back up through here and
so i tuck'n and there was one man who
was playing the part of a font in this
thing and I end and he was a friend of
one of our grad students here so I so I
thought to him about it and so on so
that was a that was a nice I think I
probably got something got to use
something else of him when he discovered
when they discovered el palo alto i
think i have a quote from him about that
Nazi font font font fray Pedro fine 139
another order another one oh we yeah
here we go we arrived at the royal de
San Francisco beside which stream is the
redwood tree I spoke of yesterday this
is the tree that that Palo Alto is named
after I measured its height with the
graph ometer so you could use the things
about numbers and roots and and dots and
numbers and sites which are very very
much like the diagram on the same page
and so and so this is this is a cook
apropos okay now when I go so let's see
so so sometimes the the the relevance of
the quotation is in the is not in the
words but in the in the in the thing
below let's see me show you that what is
uh let's the making boxes do I have
let's see boxes that was when I work
what can you say about boxes that's
interesting so so sha had another thing
in that same article about rule so the
only thing that never looks right as a
rule there is not an existence of page
with a rule
that cannot be instantly and obviously
improved by taking the rule out but
there's another thing about boxing that
I found in the OED and for this I had
this is one that I got from the British
Library because I looked up to the
original I decided to use the original
spelling of all because a lot of the
quotations come from from very old times
so I decided to use the spelling of the
in the original i looked up every single
quote you know in the original to see if
there was more than Bartlett said you
know there was something interesting
before after and boxing is is something
that doctors do they are used to do for
and to prohibit bloodletting I don't
know this I thought thought it was a
nice bloody quotation to use there but
they see boxes there is something about
boxes here we're okay here is one
Stephenson and Osborne very little does
the amateur dwelling at home at East
comprehend the labors and perils of the
author and so it's talking about the
authors peril but the the real
connection with boxes is in the is in
the title of the of their book not the
not the not the thing that they said and
that was an interesting novel that I got
that I read just to see if it has any
think it rising to say about boxes in a
novel and it was right here in chapter
one where had the best one and a movie
was made from that from that story I
have several boxes in my memory that is
just so so you know there was a in the
art of computer programming there was a
quotation from Hamlet in a temple of my
memory I will wipe away all trivial fond
from the temple of my memory I'll wipe
away all too real fond records or
something like this was just appropriate
for garbage collection
the talking about memory and records so
so to me part of the game is finding uh
just trying to find something that was
interesting that there was a little bit
out of context now let's see there was
one thing I should I guess I people in
this class will know there was like well
I tried I basically in this book pr2 to
find to to set a standard of excellence
for quotations because i enjoy library
summer and so I came back and I had most
of the problem solve and then with some
of the harder ones to go with and I had
one chapter where I just was was
completely stuck and let's see if I can
find it in them let's see if I can find
in the index because because it's a it's
something that only people only a few
people will understand why these
quotations are are interesting but I had
to fill the page with something and I
did satisfy my own let's see now look
under grim I guess I yeah page 73
this is a chapter called algebraic
expressions and I didn't know and and
the idea is that you're we're describing
pictures in terms of algebraic
expressions and here's a here are two
quotes now can anybody tell tell what I
forward what what makes these
interesting to me at least my
fascination with puns ya know that well
the actual thing was though how would I
find these particular how would i find
this particular thing about about the
Express know where it's going to express
it expression how would I how would I
actually tried mean I tell you right now
this is not an OE d this cannot be found
in any books of quotations nobody has
ever thought these these these sentences
were in any way remarkable I use the
online I have yes we have withering
Heights and we have groups Grimm's fairy
tales online and so we can do a computer
search for for them and find every use
of the word expression are expressed in
those and so I would solve that that was
silly I could you know so I decided to
put those two on the same page because
that was that was real and they are they
aren't bad quotations but I mean they're
just that was the only the only way to
get and pronounce it to get it now see
the sum of the appendices were the
hardest here and see if I if I can
remember there is something called
generic font files now generic font
files is a is a description of a file
format and
and I was able to I think find the
reference here to files if the other
kind you and then and then to get
something about Elias who set up the
whole thing is about about general and
orders and so on in botany and so you
know they found something I had to do
with files and printing because he he
referred to Jeanette generic characters
which sounds like has to do with
printing and files have to do with no
see here's another one about details
Oscar Wilde details are always vulgar
I'm talking in this chapter about about
point system of typography and so having
having the source of the when somebody
actually invents a concept is is
reasonable there's a there's an appendix
about examples in both in both of them
and and for this here by the way going
back to the original spelling was was
difficult in this in this one because it
used the old thorn character for the
four th and and I had to make a new
symbol into in the alphabet in order to
types that it but an example in doing is
more commendable than teaching or
preaching and it's a reasonably good
thing to say about examples I had the
same appendix in the tech broken I had
to have something to to write about
examples and so I gave for an example a
quote here from Mary Claire van lunin
saying the epigraph is among the most
delightful of scholarly habits Donald
Knuth work on front of mel allen would
be just as important we hadn't begun
with the quotation
Betty Crocker but not so enjoyable part
of the fun of an epigraph is turning a
source to an unexpected use and so I got
to quote her i think i was running out
of that ok and one of the things in my
chapter on examples was giving the
macros that types at this this part of
the format of this is the book has been
used as an example of itself and and so
it was reasonable to to do that now in
the previous chapter is called is called
dirty tricks and and so he I here I took
two quotations from detective stories
about shortcuts and and using using
methods that are displaying in the other
part the book not see but in the end but
I had a I found in the when I when I did
the marathon book I found out a very in
tonight looking up the word dirty and I
guess I just looking at proverbs I found
that there was a very nice proverb from
Jamaica says every house has its dirty
corner and and it's also it's true about
houses but I also thought it was
appropriate to have a corner of the
manual about dirty tricks that that
could be used for that purpose in in the
pen pendix a in both books was was about
was about answers to exercises and I
need a lot of quotations about answers
to exercises because because the other
computer programming each each book has
has has answered exercises and so on so
I I was allowed to quote myself again
here by quoting the preface to refer to
the answers and then there's a
Shakespeare Shakespeare you cannot be
confined by looking up in the in the
complete concordance ha's of Shakespeare
to see when he what he had to say about
answers just call these fowl offenders
to their answers I think that was kind
of kind of nice another place
Shakespeare had said here I'll answer
you for yourselves and I put that second
because I I use the same quote from the
report from the tech book this time in
the tech book to to indicate that a
person does the dancers go this way and
see the very last stuff the very last
Missy that index is another one and I
thought I needed a lot of quotations
because most of my books have indexes
and so in the art of computer
programming I found a wonderful thing
when I was reading an old Sears Roebuck
catalogue they have reprinted some of
the old catalogs and I looked through it
browsing and I noticed that it said in
there if you can't find it in the index
look very carefully throughout the
entire catalog oh my god and oh that's
in our computer i've already used that
and so i have to and so so what i found
is but i did find a man who wrote this
in his book he says I so essential that
i consider an index to be to every book
that i propose to bring a bill into
Parliament to deprive an author who
publishes a book without an index the
privilege of copyright moreover to
subject him for pecuniary penalty yet
from difficulty started by my printers
my own books have hitherto been without
an index you know and that was in the
meta phone book in the tech book the
it's about typesetting and so I got to
use quotations of
from saying that important works should
have an index and so then it tells about
an index but this was one of my
favorites from the biography of pdq bach
important references are given in
boldface tile size numbers indicate
fleeting references whereas numbers
princes refer to mirror implications are
unwarranted extrapolations asterisks
that used to identify particularly
distasteful pacifism well I hope you
could understand why I think this is fun
and and also perhaps worthwhile to
broaden to broaden perspective it's a
it's a it's a it's a hunt that is
exciting I think to anybody who is not
real narrow minded and to me the most
like I just recommend trying to go and
break play libraries as musical
instruments of yoyo feel fine and blood
of a player